[Music]
last time i used my
um all those toys like in all those
blocks and then make like robots
i don't know
so at the end of this program i want all
the kids to to know that they're
creative but not only that to know that
creativity is something that they want
as part of their lives that it's a way
of looking at the world that means they
are observant they are curious and that
it's also a way to solve problems in
their life but also in the world around
them
people may think that hey creativity is
just part of art and craft no creativity
is something that you can apply as part
of a mindset in all situations beyond
all the subjects that you learned
we are connected to aya
through the
design singapore council their specialty
is really in using vibrant images
animation and all that and
actually helps students to develop
divergent thinking which is something
very very important
my favorite one is this picture
because it looks
like bluish purple which is my favorite
color
factories are releasing carbon dioxide
and people are throwing away like
devices i love ice cream
and
i just want to eat it
and our teacher go and let us put crazy
answers then i say put a gigantic air
conditioner on top of the whole
singapore you can put eyes all
underground
so the cooler the cold
floor there may be like you know small
little pieces of you know plastic that
is called my
pro
it's micro something
[Music]
[Applause]
uh
wait wait
what i was gonna say
creativity you can like
you can think of better ways to like do
something
to
like solve the problem that you have you
know how i know it works the students
just look forward to the lessons that is
the clearest indicator that something is
going on well here because of the fact
that it gets them to answer creatively
there's no wrong answer and that's how i
know that something has stuck inside
them that will extend beyond this lesson
to be really truly creative it's it's a
lifestyle choice and it's constantly
exercising those muscles so i think that
the students will have had a taste of it
and they will have enjoyed it
for it to continue we would want the
program these type of activities to
continue for the long term creativity is
using imagination to solve problems
creativity is
working with friends and
thinking about new ideas
creativity can come in many ways
like you just think of a funny thing and
then you like slowly see how it can link
back to the topic you're on
[Music]